I've never listened to anybody when you
ask them what's their flaw it's the
biggest [ __ ] humblebrag of all time
I'm such an expert that like sometimes I
make my team struggle to keep up with my
awesomeness
[Music]
so this portion is like with me so I
think this is when you need to get
selfish like you ask your question you
know the you don't have to worry about
everybody else what I've learned for
doing some of these is a lot of themes
matter some are very close businesses
things that nature but theoretically a
lot of us are dealing with HR stuff for
growth stuff so I think you'll get a lot
out I want to I want to hedge to make
sure you're asking your question as if
it was just us so you get your answer so
okay please we over the years we've our
first business first foremost is
easiness listed for speaker that's like
that space everything that's on top
we've had it for 10 years
run we have three brokerages out in
Arizona but we implemented do the work
so we have the coaching consulting so
but now against is the question we've
always been coaching our agents we have
over 130 135 that are in the brokerage
we've always coached them through
business personal and everything so
we've been part of their lives when we
created do the work it started as the
coaching the consulting business but
this is the problem when agents come up
or they're constantly marketing to the
work so where they're out there you know
so but now a lot of people are kind of
confused what do you do are you coaching
consulting are your brokerage because
agents market do the work constantly at
Eden associates so when you log on to
our pages it's kind of like are they
agents when you're marketing to the work
it's like an agency a real estate agency
or coaching consulting so it gets
well okay so are you worried about that
cuz it's sound it sounds like a it
sounds like a ui/ux issue more than
anything else meaning you know what runs
through my mind when I hear that and as
you can imagine like my life can get
quite confusing too I mean we have all
sorts of [ __ ] going on I mean people are
always computer there's a lot of people
who think I'm literally just a public
speaker like you know there's a lot of
confusion I think the question becomes
if you're creating less confusion with
your core websites like you could create
a bar at the top of both of your
websites the realist you know the the
agent part world and the branding
Consulting thing that literally
navigates people to the proper place if
they're looking for one or the other I'm
trying to figure out is so the energy is
created the top of the funnel is created
then they go somewhere and if they
thought they were going to coaching and
consulting but they're over here I think
it just becomes a matter of like how
much clarity do you want to create on
the two separate businesses web sites
and do you have to separate business
websites I mean you could on the main
business the trencher business have
something at time that says are you
looking for do the work consulting click
here that literally solves your problem
a lot going on and off to the word we
have so much material and you want to
do the work even associates rates it's
growing and it's there it's kind of
running this I want to say it that way
that will snap and everything but now
it's him and I will do the work we have
so much material out there because I'm
at with merchandise and so we want to
start selling that this is a super this
is a super common thing there's so many
people that start a business and then
get into a place of whether it's burnout
whether it's excitement for the second
baby right it's it's a hundred percent
so I think what here's what I would say
first and foremost what you need to do
is not create a framework that creates
vulnerability to the first business
emotionally not financially like your
employees that work for that company
will know if your energy skewing too
much to number two that's what matters
not I landed and I'm confused you can
fix that in a Google search I just an H
bar that I just told you to make got it
you know like that's your issue and it's
not it doesn't have to be an issue it's
the issue that the cliche move that
people like you always create which is
you want to create the perception that
you're fully focused on number one but
your actions are too obvious to any
normal human being that you're excited
about number two I say you own being
excited about number two but you never
make number one feel compromised because
you create infrastructure including very
simple moves no different than as simple
as I told you to create an h-hello bar
up top you could promote an internal
person to be President and give them a
little more autonomy you know like
there's things you could do and I think
I've been at my worse when I've tried to
juggle too many things in my own head
and I've become a much better version of
myself by leaning all into the clarity
on where the [ __ ] I am which is why I've
over-exaggerated my entrepreneurship
because you know at some level everybody
hears like well he's an entrepreneur
look at anything's possible company
sometimes I like you do know that next
Tuesday you may walk in and I might
change this entire thing into a company
that sells hot dogs and and it's because
it's
so I think that to me is what smells in
a way that doesn't have to be bad that's
what you need to reconcile like if
you're you know if you're trying to
create life is good like you know like
you know like don't worry be happy and
like coaching and consulting underneath
it like that's amazing it's highly
profitable it's the new thing it's like
I understand it but you need to
reconcile the past in a fair way in
whatever that may be but nobody's gonna
get tricked and over time that will
become your vulnerability and so like
making a video or standing for the
company be like yep
we're 63% here and 37% here and guess
what our 63 and our 37% over here is
gonna make this even better and our 63
plus the hail that's what I do like like
vaynermedia is the beneficiary of Gary
Vee becoming a mod I'm just giving money
what the [ __ ] is this
I don't need vaynermedia you don't pay
for me so like I proved to Steve Ross
and my brother and myself that me
building Gary Vee over the last four
years has benefited vaynermedia do you
have any partners in the first business
well guess what you're set so guess what
you're set
nobody's gonna have to sit there and be
like I'll [ __ ] they're gonna care more
there cuz they own a hundred of that and
only fit right now you just have to
create a little more clarity internally
at business one that's your
vulnerability makes sense a lot cool
it's just it is it is that it is always
that and there's people like me who are
able to have Wine Library and one day
when I'm not the CEO vaynermedia still
be evergreen businesses that are awesome
and all that work you put in and the
nurse people who lose the first one out
of trying to [ __ ] entrepreneurs I'm
bored right now
yeah I'd say that's constable costing
building new things and we're just kind
of like okay just be authentically you
and be smart about how this is why I
build relationships with people because
like there may be a point where you need
to it's a it's a win-win people get more
opportunity and you get to scratch your
riches I guess really my biggest
struggle right now was like I guess
falling apart in a comparative spot to
you it's figuring where the gap is to go
off of stacking and go on the offensive
when it's not a monetary number and the
monetary side is easy so if you're still
stacking for an offensive it's not here
I'm in a similar mindset to you where
like I don't want destruction but I do
like any would like to wake up and see
that they made it you know start the
progressive progress in China with
tariffs and everything I don't like that
I'm looking for the reverse but it's
because I've been in that zone and it's
in a spot where everything I want to
build currently or have got off track or
not nor valuev entreprenuer real venue
or venture is that I go into stuff that
I can do and it's about collecting the W
flag yep don't you fly gonna walk yes
but what's the but one time when there's
only one of you when there's the time
set it's the money and ability to stack
darts and bullets come really easy but
take away the intime to be creative and
when you get into hiring your weakness
my weakness is hiring well good news I
think that if your weakness is hiring it
only means that you're just a
compassionate good guy because you
haven't figured out that it's about
firing and you've heard this really I I
think I'll tell you how I figured it out
somewhat big exit packages
I hate firing too because I feel bad and
I don't care about money so that put me
in a shitty spot cuz I could make it
just like if you can make money
you never value the thing that comes to
you
so somewhere along line based on how big
my ambitions are and I'm running pretty
big companies
I just realized okay like I'm just
better off hiring somebody three months
in and giving them four months severance
than just sitting in my yeah but that's
that's that's my dream but that doesn't
work either right like it's implicate
what do you think well that's Thursday
like I don't got a date but like this
company wants to pay me two thousand
bucks to come do a shoot for photography
which is his okay got it yeah I got it
worry about it they're not people look
back at myself without hiring the person
that can actually take care of that it
all depends on what it depends on your
ego and control and insecurities and and
how you feel about the people you hire
to me hiring yeah but your [ __ ] yeah
they don't teach you all right enjoy
yeah yep same thing yeah [ __ ] class
yep it's the white is I get it I get it
reading from both that is ready three
years ago on how to do something in an
era I work in isn't worthless book I
look I if you're looking to hire a CEO
or an operator or a black and white
person I think you just hire and fire in
perpetuity
I would also is it higher like the pools
an easy spot fine looking even though
the process is the hard part
well that you proven process I think is
where a lot of it comes up not if you
overpay not if you overpay I mean
finding somebody who can operate
anything is stunningly easy I don't know
what mental roadblock is in your head
right now that makes you think you can't
bind them or the pool is hard it's easy
because you go and watch something you
go take it from somewhere where they've
already are doing it there's surveys you
can there's sort of things instinctively
you can't
the same way I can't there's certain
parts of my business that I can't let go
which is you don't you you don't give
that to that person sure that's the core
of the stacking to go on the offensive
so then you eat [ __ ] and you stack the
rational worthless I mean I get it I
guess it's based on a playoff spot like
you know I mean like you know you
I've given I'll give you an example I
know it sounded you're saying I've given
up a ton of money over the last 36
months at vaynermedia to create the
operational infrastructure we I gave up
new business we haven't sold anything
for two years but but real quick just to
use but it's what helped me get to be
able to work with now in a way that's
about to be so transformative we've been
able six years doing a bucks ten bucks
like you know into it if this year goes
the way I think it's going to I don't
even want to dream but you know outside
of their own macro will the company sell
and activist investors and what are they
up to which is what sucks about client
services compared to starting a business
that you control like retail or things
that nature but yeah I mean look I think
I totally understand that I understand
exactly what you're saying
here's the problem continuing to stack
and the world doesn't collapse for
another thirty four months you'd be like
[ __ ] I should have hired the operational
thing over there like that's my thing
like spaces are opening like furnace
unless by like the weed space is opening
it's a good space between the
influencing music rappers anti greatness
everything I've done in the past they
over themselves but at this point so if
you want the only status for the
satisfying thing outside of like fun
yeah let's call them and like W flag in
the smallest thing like going and
crushing logical you're not doing the
garage sale thing for money yeah of
course really enjoy the act of that like
yeah same thing like don't want to go
you don't find lemonade stands and like
yeah these kids how to like really yeah
it hasn't been fun yes absolutely but
the point is like we're so long-term
value
have that play like it was always too
stacked put everybody in a position I
think what everybody else in position
and it don't want to do with myself I
think that's the flip like I still live
in the same house I had before all this
because I move to the next house I'm
changing my position I got it the
underdog position I get it but it's
finding that spot to attack when you've
really been playing passive i-i-i think
that makes a ton of a ton of sense to me
here's what i can tell you you will be a
disproportionately resentful person if
you over value the next at-bat so I'm
talking about this crash a lot which is
what you're referring to it's funny how
much I've been thinking about the next
one so like I've been like laughing cuz
I'm like [ __ ] what if tomorrow
everything does melt what if tomorrow is
Bear Stearns like am i exactly as ready
as I've been talking yes
no like I just what you're young I just
wouldn't like if you put everything on
I've eaten [ __ ] for 15 years and now
I've got to take advantage of this next
downturn for me it's like sure but
there'll be two downturns in 20 years
and how old are you right now yeah I'm
like dude or you doing a 56 like I think
you need to think some of the pressure
off of nailing it perfectly on this one
because I'm definitely doing that with
myself look every time a hundred percent
yeah that's honestly that's easy because
like if you meaning you have to it's
about self-awareness and what makes you
happy right like like you just have like
it's easy to find games to win you just
make you just change your mind on what
that game is like if the Jets win
back-to-back Super Bowls in three years
it'll be the Knicks and enough KD signs
here Knicks win a championship
then I'll be like you know what I'm
gonna start okay I'm gonna build the
greatest K through 12 business schools
in America 30 of them so like that's on
you that's yet to shift we have more we
have more time tonight I want to get to
everybody so them do that
Hey
okay.what bringing you in value at all
excuse me I apologize yeah so totally
easy to explain right so being in thing
is we're very in bound working yep so
majority of companies are not a
headquartered in baby that's a the
transactions either gotta be at CBA or
because they're feeding it that's it
yeah that's it so what I knew perfect I
was working two jobs I was working on my
dad's place and then working in hip I
started college for kepner's and
realized that was yeah yep they weren't
bringing yep market so for five years I
haven't focused on things at all I focus
on how estate brokers right so we marked
everybody in New York a typical la San
Francisco cetera it's been really
successful seen about three hundred
percent year-over-year growth until this
year
pretty flat was last year so now I'm
like oh [ __ ] why do you think that
happened well speak I think why it
happened is because we don't go after a
lot of our own clients where we've been
more focusing on going after the brokers
that control the clients right you know
the leopard spray so I've had some aha
moments growing up in the restaurant for
me it's all about service right so when
I was a waiter I was advocating 25% tips
pretty good and it's based off service
and so the only simple negative customer
service the little details into my
business we did a deal in Vegas with a
big national law firm and a very
sophisticated client if you will and she
said I'm doing the deal in LA Dallas New
York and Vegas you need to teach all
these other guys had a service a client
aha moment we just got back from Irvine
with a client for 3,000 feet he
literally emailed the global president
of the company talking about the service
we're delivering so we want to be able
to bring the bat service to anybody in
everybody okay what I love about what we
do on the tenor website is my business
its fiduciary set up to wholly provide
value to the
I tell people I make less money if the
better I do my job that's right love I
got it
now I can help you hire that new
employee didn't have dollars for get you
those three extra months of free rent
and that it if you prove it it's
leverage
it's what my agency's doing in the
marketing world yeah so for us we hear
and consider to be in that higher tier
of people actively involved on social
media okay from the commercial real
estate standpoint but we're doing it
with no plate look if you will so my
goal here today is to learn the recipe
right keep learning how to cook the meal
versus just reading the recipe I
understand and what that are our end
game is to be able to get our message
out to a point where I'm doing zero
transaction Airi work we're starting to
build the team so we're hiring a CEO for
the team or hiring a transaction area
broker
so we're client interface but once the
deal gets to a point of having to
negotiate it because there's a process
we police's that's off my plate and we
want to grow the brand to where we're
not Vegas at all we just want people to
know that the commercial real estate
team if you need help in any market and
don't know who to call you call us we'll
be your single point of contact will be
the plain interface we'll make sure the
service delivery is there while using
the local market expert to get you the
best deal possible I mean that's why
we're here right and so for me it's
really just trying to understand the
method to the madness My partner and I
have very similar strengths and very
similar weaknesses so we're we're trying
to figure it out so real quick I just
want to get some clarification you
what's that
no I get that but that would mean
starting your own company to sit on top
of we'd have to you'd have to
unfortunately and
like I was on a panel and our national
conference in Miami couple months ago
and I'm talking in the room about
high-performance teams I'm like guys
we're just starting to be a
high-performance team and how we got
here was branding and marketing
let me tell all of you that record
they're not spending a dollar on any of
you right and branding and our CMO is in
the room and she's sat me down and gave
me this whole spiel only but it's the
truth and the more we paying ourselves
the more that brings the company value
right from a social standpoint yeah but
they don't want that because then you'll
have leverage right yes ESPN controls
how much airtime sports casters have you
don't have the leverage the only
leverage you have is controlling your
expenses to let you leave to start up
your business so what I would do is I
would build your personal brand with
content at scale all the things that you
said on that panel on LinkedIn in
perpetuity while Lincoln's unbelievably
organically strong keep building keep
building so that you wake up one morning
and after forty seven emails came in
that night like I want you to work for
me how do you work like you just have
that moment where the practical not not
be emotional the practical data staring
you in the face and you've been saving
along the way same house same house
standing along the way and like I live
in I've could have upgraded my New York
City apartment for the last five years
in a row I haven't because I live it I
believe in it that's and I'm happy I
think for you know the thought of
somebody controlling me the way that
they control you is not happy it's not
right and we until this year we weren't
a corporate job we've always been under
the flag and so previous ownership like
I'd always bring my issues like guys
this is [ __ ] they were just so
exciting up for sale and they were like
we virgin great yeah that's cute right
now part of the big corporates like even
harder to get what we're trying to
achieve you'll never achieve it right
nor should you it's not the game they're
playing they don't care and they can't
help it I have empathy for that global
CEO he's like that's fine but I can't
take the financial hit to invest for 24
months to change this organization's DNA
because if I'm down 13 percent
year-over-year I'm gonna get fired by
the board you have to build your brand
at scale I would recommend LinkedIn
content at scale that's like a lot
you're basically every every second that
you're not putting into building your
brand's content to give you leverage to
be able to leap and saving money on
whatever money you're making and not
spending money at home you'll be stuck
you're in golden handcuffs you'll be
stuck forever yeah I mean like one of
the things I'm trying to do is now get
people to downgrade for happiness like
in real life scenarios where I know more
details I'm like trying to convince
friends to sell their home I'm like you
can leave tomorrow yeah there you go you
need to find yourself a year's worth of
runway and go that's it because you
could always get a job again like like
[ __ ] so you suck then you weren't as
good as you thought and in Mun ten
you're like [ __ ] I blow and I'm going to
be C you know now the economy can
collapse during that timing and then all
of it gets tougher but that's just
business
recessions don't scary I agree I mean I
think one of things that always scare me
about like dtc products that are so
obvious right now is like you know what
happens you know especially premium
stuff like what happens it's just
something you have to go through that's
why being over leveraged your first step
bad is always scary to me so where a lot
of people get burned because you've
never knew what it's like when you get
337 orders on Amazon every day and then
it's seven I had a refund eight hundred
thousand dollars worth of wine in one
hour after Bear Stearns collapsed and I
never saw that it's honestly like I've
been talking about it for two [ __ ]
years it's not even been super right
like like right like I mean I guess I'm
kind of right because Amazon and
Facebook and Netflix are down a lot in
stock over the last six my leg it feels
right but like it's it's honestly the
reason I'm talking about it is because
the delusion in the other directions
accelerating even faster yeah
it's not that I think it's gonna happen
tomorrow it's just like kids are like
kids are committing suicide because they
over leveraged their credit cards to buy
Bitcoin because it was gonna go to a
hundred thousand a coin like there needs
to be a practical voice in the ecosystem
that is at least charismatic enough to
maybe penetrate all these knuckleheads I
feel a sense of responsibility to not
even kidding there's not a lot of
characters with sizzle like me that can
get through a twenty three-year-old
alpha guy and be like wait a minute I
should save my money because everything
else is like you know girls and
champagne and Lamborghinis they're
completely being sold to over-exaggerate
which means over-leveraged which means
bad stuff especially the big fear I have
right now is that we've never had this
much public losses the last time the
economy collapsed there wasn't a
generation of people with audiences
telling them that they were the best
businessmen of all time and then had to
take a loss this one's gonna hurt
emotionally and I don't think a lot of
kids were built to take that kind of al
so I'm worried
and it's gonna be ugly it's gonna be bad
it's gonna be bad
like what do you do you your role Xing
and flexing and now like you have to go
work at a company and you don't want to
like people are not good people gonna
lose and then not want to get a job to
start the five year process to get back
because they don't want to look bad on
social media so what you gonna do you're
gonna triple down on bad behavior shit's
gonna get ugly so that's why really
that's what you need to do bro the
internet will squeeze everybody the
internet is the middleman everybody's
industry will just it's just a moment
entire like either your the bookstores
and the limo drivers are caught now
rocket mortgage leopard all this giraffe
on it the internet will take everything
I don't think voice is your biggest
issue right like yes do I think in nine
years it's possible that I say hey Alexa
you know get me the best mortgage rate
yes I think Amazon will own that or
Google or whoever pays them a fuckload
to be the result if you're in the middle
you you are vulnerable in a twenty year
window that's my official point the
problem is if that's seventeen years
from now when it gets real bad where it
really hurts well how are you gonna play
that or is that four years from now that
has to do with other entrepreneurs
bookstores didn't have to be first that
was Jeff Bezos is doing right limos
didn't have to be next that was Travis
is doing personal brands are super not
pumped with me if you still four hundred
dollar ebooks right now I'm a problem
right like hey you know there you go so
right that's just like that's what's
happening and it's playing out in front
of everybody's eyes because I'm also
it's not just that I'm getting the
market I'm inspiring the next people for
a different model did it it it out so I
think you're I think it's in trouble but
I think that leads to opportunity right
but I think being eyes wide open I don't
think we're buying mortgages through
Alexa in the next five years but an
eight maybe and you know what I think
that's something to think about I will
because I will value anything else it's
just data you know certain things will
still end listen there's always a market
for high-touch I think you go super
premium or super discount and everything
in the middle is garbage yeah and so
more more to me it's like the Internet's
won and the guy in the Galvez willing to
go to the person's house pick them up
out of bed sit them down make them a
fresh juice drink and then go through
all their finances got it that's who's
gonna win that's the only people that
are gonna be around in a 50 year window
right it's kind of like every industry
if you look at it plays that out
I think the Internet's gonna make it
more extreme I'd much rather own an 80
$18 bar direct-to-consumer than a $3 bar
harder but like in my thesis plays out
better if you're able to pull it off
I'd rather get like the tears of a seal
you know ingredient you know that's how
I think about it so I did the wine that
I just did right it's you know if you
look at direct-to-consumer if you look
at what people are drinking like you
know it's a 20 it's a $40 rose' for 20
bucks like that's a premium rose' so
that's what I would think about so 30
seconds of boring background to get to
the question we're the ones doing the
fuller stuff that's under this this
broader umbrella of beam distributing so
in a lot of cases for the cooler
business which was then pretty darn well
for us we are sort of defer to make it
overly simple like a partner to on you
know bringing products to market and
getting about them also sells them but
we are technically a separate entity so
I guess where my question goes and this
is one that we pontificated over a
couple of belts at the hotel bar is does
it make sense to start growing something
that is completely agnostic to another
brand that at the end of the day has say
in control over course this is all about
leverage the end it just it just is it
just is whoever has the leverage will
milk the provider for when they need
them and as soon as they don't they
won't now you may say well we make it
better or we do this better until you
don't like there could be a day when
that happens other entrepreneurs or your
own ambitions or needs being at the
mercy of anything is a bad business
eventually it just is but but but
building a brand is not as easy as it
sounds right that's why people are
willing to be at the mercy of Adidas and
Nike and and you know a you know a
little bit extra nuance on that we've
gotten pretty good at
the marketing machine you know make more
dollars in women is the first part that
you said I apologize is the first part
of b2b business
we're split in two
mm-hmm so it's 2/3 b2b in theory yeah I
mean yeah
respect but you 1/3 of your business is
consumer and that business is a website
that sells all coolers just right that's
[ __ ] think you're gonna have to do
something about that meaning it [ __ ] the
most macro might be phenomenal it's
great it's a good brand you're better at
marketing than they are
so you have some leverage right now but
you're not because they make one hire
and you're not you can't be your
leverage can't be you're better at CAC
and LTV than they are cost of customer
at customer acquisition cost
like if you're better at selling coolers
than they are on their separate website
cuz you're better at CAC than they are
that's a bad bad bad place to be in
because if they can just hire
vaynermedia and I'll beat you next year
and then you have no leverage for the
same leverage you had and so then they
can start [ __ ] you around whatever
that I don't know that enough details
you had like exclusive contracts how do
they compensate you didn't to the death
they will 100% eventually only sell
themselves you're doing the dirty work
for them to build up the leverage they
have to go figure how do you feel about
since we know that space you know much
better than
at random doing something similar versus
versus picking up you know Margaret that
we think makes sense or just some more
if you're willing to well can you write
in a dream world we're making rhinoceros
and going whatever
it's said I would literally Google what
animal kills the most people and start
that brand like literally literally
that's what I would do
literally literally I would create you
know it literally would create like
shark like II know like well you know
you know I would start that now the
question becomes can you based on the
deal you have with them even if it
wasn't in a contract as soon as you show
that look what does that mean how much
revenue is that driving for you are you
willing to go to everything to be a zero
the fact that I'm so crazy that I'm
willing to walk outside right now leave
this whole thing and start at zero again
like I did this thing is why all my
partners treat me the way that I do
because they know it to be true that's
the best leverage right so do you have
the leverage like to me what schools you
have two-thirds of other business so to
me it's like if you know the inevitable
like like to me it's like going the
offense versus the defense the best case
is the advice I gave him which is can
you establish walrus you know coolers
now and not create conflict with can you
be cute for two years
yeah well jump look at everybody and
that and that has a lot to do with the
question that I was gonna have is is
like we accept the inevitable that it
will eventually all be direct from them
whether that's a 5 or 10 year window
like you know but the transition from
now until then my question is aside from
just sheer volume how can we increase
the leverage we
starting a separate brand so deliberate
you are so wrong about that brother the
leverage is not gonna be your leverage
the volume is not gonna be your leverage
you know it's just not it's not
elaborate it's actually will speed up
the process of them leaving their letter
shrinking it's not even that guys it's
you know when you own the brand and use
a third-party vendor it's just any trip
like I don't know enough right but like
if we were like over a five-hour dinner
if I was your cousin I'd be like bro
what if they get funding what if they do
a cash infusion what if somebody buys
the company who's a d'art like there is
no five to ten years it can be tomorrow
outside of me not knowing the contract
sure and you're right it could be in
Kobe's farm so I guess the impetus of
the question is how do we how do we ease
that transition for ourselves by
starting the process of building the
brand it you'll notice and I think this
is kind of like so much of my success
I'm just even when I don't like what's
going through my own head for myself
it's always binary it's a super binary
you know what what happens is you get
golden handcuffs and you start trying to
justify to yourself why it's not gonna
happen you're spending all your time in
the shower and in your bed when you know
brushing your teeth walking down the
street justifying why it's gonna be four
years not one year because you like what
you're getting I hate that that to me is
anxiety I'd rather like I almost you
know like I'd rather cut bait and bounce
you know then they have they have
something like that sit over my head
thus since I don't think you should cut
bait and just cancel shut down the
company you should create walrus and if
walrus starts doing anything of any kind
that gets them bothered or like you
better stop walrus or we're done you
like you gotta go like you got to
basically cut it off and then kind of
hope that it takes longer for them that
is the only anecdote to create leverage
in a third party seller environment it's
a hundred percent it and it's a lot of
people lose in this scenario a lot
yeah cuz they're doing what you're doing
which I have empathy for I don't think
it's I don't think it's wrong as a human
it's a hundred percent right wrong as a
business you don't have the leverage and
the world is the other thing if the lair
is the macro world the world is going
more DTC you know pump these guys are
that they're not them they're she's
worried about Walmart and Costco they
have all the lab all of the leverage
these guys I got Shopify Amazon this
phone no nothing
their problem is that like these two
[ __ ] characters every single person's
gonna create a [ __ ] bar and go direct
to consumers so it's a huge opportunity
but everybody's in it when when she was
selling being in the business in America
in 1999 or 2006 was impossible either
drill Ian's dollars just to make it just
to get into [ __ ] you have much money
cost to get into Costco or Walmart er
now it's game over man it's all going
the internet will eat everything
including the media including retail all
of it
CMI my bars are 608 bar so I played a
little bit in the higher-priced space
hundred percent direct consumer like
actively turning down retailers the
inside I'm hoping to glean is about half
of our revenues from Shopify half is
from sales funnels click miles having
seenu's be care click funnels know some
of those guys they're really preaching
that click funnels are like the new
website I want to get your insights ask
for it
I want to make sure I it yeah I want to
make sure I understand the full clarity
of click funnels cuz obviously I'm
spoken there I understand the theme but
I want to understand break down the
whole click because it sounds like
somebody else is gonna have leverage so
[Music]
I would say both because what a website
can what click funnels do at their best
is give you great sales but [ __ ] your
brand cuz it looks like [ __ ] even if you
make it good what a website does is it
can look great so like your website can
have that anchor video that's your
Dollar Shave Club video and you can get
the brand across right I kind of look at
click funnels theoretically as like
things like outlet stores are shipping
it to other countries it's like a way to
move inventory but you don't necessarily
want your brand directly associated with
especially when you're selling a six
dollar [ __ ] product if it doesn't
look it field apart as much of like a
six dollar brothers there's a reason
that Cartier's website looks the way it
does everybody in that world in the
Idaho off psyche know like they all care
about sales there's a very specific
reason I am Who I am I'm brand the end
there's a lot of people that sell forty
nine million dollars worth of t-shirts
and sales but they're not polo right
it's landing page optimization at scale
it's like theoretical psychological
arbitrage like if you look at he's got
multiple sites that when you land just
does a better job of getting you to buy
the [ __ ] product it's got really
dirty DNA from like early internet
marketing like [ __ ] you know but but but
to the credit like it's evolving to like
being more clean
thus you know it's trying to find out
it's kind of meat like listen at some
level I'm I'm really good at sales and
branding and that's why having tension
between both is why I'm able to be
successful I do think that you are
giving up brand because look first
impressions matter like I don't know
what to say
like are you gonna marry the person that
you like hook up with at 3:30 in the
morning in a Vegas club maybe but like
it's a different context of meeting that
person than if you met at a coffee shop
it's just different
they're both ry+ there's all you know
there's other things like but like but I
do think it matters I do think it
matters and I think that's how I think
about brand right I know what they would
say you're throwing money away in the
long term is how I look at it which is
why most those people become
cryptocurrency experts six years later
got it
they're always chasing fast bucks
finding the balance though because
because that's my my DNA understands
that and then just obviously what's the
open timing yeah what's up with timing I
got 20 or yeah
yeah okay it's the reverse and brand
land there so in outer space on brand
there's no level of practicums nothing
picking macro macro right like there so
like let's do a TV commercial and buy
billboard and just brand and not
practical so they're too far there mmm
the world that you're talking abouts to
far there and that's why I think my spot
has been so good for me but I will
always lean closer to her than that
world like I will never sacrifice brand
I would I joined I'm eight million
dollar check to go to China for 30
minutes and film a video but I knew it
was for a network marketing product that
was full of [ __ ] and I wasn't willing to
give up my brand in China for it it's
hard to pass up on an eight million
dollar paycheck for 30 minutes you know
takes discipline this was like four
years ago to when it was like less
obvious that China was as easy to like
more it was less than I was less than a
global mindset was like guys you know
George Clooney does that [ __ ] right they
you know Brad Pitt they love going to
like Japan and do a commercial but you
don't see it here I'm like that's Mar
you know like you know it depends on
what you Trump now again this is what I
kind of started with like when I jumped
in inappropriately on Antonia because I
got excited about the question you know
if you think a private equity firms on
the verge of buying you and you're like
that take a blast of like 10 more
million in profit some it's you always
have to contextualize these answers but
yes that's the answer
[Music]
yep no number two you said
and looking at more just consulting
helping people kind of built tech
companies you read a lot of books
radical candor things like that it
doesn't really apply with Google they do
this really yeah it's not real really
writing a lot of do you see any downside
to self-publish versus going yeah I
think self-publishing has less brand
equity I'd rather give up the economics
which I do you know I would say watch
what I do not what I say
I don't self publish eyeball the
leverage
HarperCollins sells zero books when I
sell them Tommy
why am I willing to give up 50 cents on
dollar because the brand association
with self-publishing is not as good as
the publishing it's gotten way better
a decade later than it was you know 20
15 years ago no we're making some eye
contact of this you were like 15 years
ago it was for the scum of the scum it's
way better it's way better way better
listening to your narrative back to
contextual if you're trying to make that
leap to have brand equity to leverage I
think it would help you to make get a
[ __ ] $10,000 advance from Simon &
Schuster to have that versus
self-publishing in my opinion it's hot
takes matter you know and a hot take on
you like quick read on you first time I
hear of you because you wrote a good
medium piece and your book is Simon
Shuster vs. self-publishing it will
matter I think for what your actual goal
is which is to leverage that to do some
consulting get some equity right I mean
look this is there's a funny thing to
say it's every piece of my behavior is
based on that advice I'm basically
trying to be the best person ever to
every entrepreneur just in case I fall
short eventually in 23 years for the
Jets and I can rally 50,000 people to
give me a one hundred fifty thousand
dollars each like I'm not even kidding
yeah I mean like when I kickstart the
entire Jets process people be like how
the [ __ ] did it happen it was gonna be
31 years of work where I brought more
value than I took
otherwise I'd be taking like a
[ __ ] been making fifty million
dollars a year just being Gary B being
on an island mastermind [ __ ] $400,000
ahead that you know all those [ __ ]
make fun of me they make fun of me
behind their back all the time that's
what they tell the kids he's stupid he
doesn't make as much money as he should
cuz they're playing short I'm playing
long a sprinter thinks a marathon
runners stupid they lost the race right
life is long
life is [ __ ] long that's where
everybody got confused especially with
the way we're you know life is long it's
why I want people to cut their costs
down because if you can make it through
the recession that's coming whenever it
comes three years from now tomorrow
you'll be in a really nice spot but do
you love what you sell do you love what
you do because that's the only way you
can get through those years because if
you're indifferent of money right if you
you know I don't know you guys but if
it's like oh [ __ ] there's this Expo West
and I'm gonna go they're gonna M&A and
buy in three years and I'm just gonna
arbitrage the internet and flip it and
be like [ __ ] Dollar Shave Club well
then that's not the game you're playing
about there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that you just have to know what
game you're playing and you can't be
full of [ __ ] to yourself right back to
the cooler thing right can't people the
only moaner ability in business is when
you're bullshitting yourself out of what
you hope is gonna happen versus what's
actually happening that's why I've been
good cuz I'm pivoting all the time
I've got hopes and dreams of how it play
out to every day but I don't navigate
and anything but the reality so yeah I
think I think to be very frank I don't
think a book carries that much weight
altogether I'd much rather you start a
podcast that you're doing weekly and
writing on LinkedIn and putting out
white papers and just [ __ ] going you
know I like the book though I'd like it
I just want I want to make sure that you
don't over value it cuz it doesn't carry
anywhere close to the way they used to
ya know no you're fine
I'm not against that here let's go very
macro put out as much of your best
advice as possible first low-cost as
possible and a lot of good things will
happen it just will because you're
competing against a lot of content so
you want to create the least amount of
friction that's why I make my content in
all forms you like listening while you
run I'm here for you you like reading
good
you like watching videos surely got that
covered you want micro videos yep got it
look at the lack of friction I create
I've got every format of consumption and
I've got every distribution channel
while everybody else is getting sucked
in just being on Instagram answer Tom's
gonna be myspace one day it happens to
everybody so got it and then and then I
talk a lot about self-awareness are you
better writer are you good on video are
you weird on video but you're good on
audio figure out how you communicate to
the world and do that there's you know
I'm always worried that people try to be
like me you know like you need to be
unique the only way people should be
like me is they should be self-aware and
you know so I guess start so in the
transition period sold most of my retail
stores now I've won laughs and so I'm
really focused in on building my
nutrition lines now
we're currently doing like 80% wholesale
in subscription box and then 20% strike
a consumer she'll find Amazon I'm trying
to make that shift and really make it a
direct consumer brand and I'm actually
kind of have a little bit a hangover
retail so now it's like finally like I'm
ready to build you know this
organization around it I'm kind of
looking for the next steps on who to
bring on an outsource everything up to
this point I'm a one-man show matha
North yeah you're only the method or
business okay so just the cadence of how
you want to figure out your math okay
I'd like to have one of each to start
though that's all this is this whole
[ __ ] thing is one big game of math
and art equally respecting itself
and then the the plan is to kind of
develop into the nutrition business is
pretty shady there's a lot of street
characters in it so my idea and help
build my personal brand too is to create
a line extension that's essentially like
to take from the wine business single
vineyard kind of supplement so basically
from form to bottle yeah interact that
process ship full weight on it super
smart so what I what I did with the wine
project we literally filmed everything
I'm a year and a half from the first
meeting we decided to do it to like
being at the farm being like all that
[ __ ] that will work transparency will
work hundred thousand percent it's crazy
they did it scares me I'm crazy oh I
mean I hate the industry yeah I'm scared
shitless of it the amount of people
private labeling [ __ ] they have no idea
what the [ __ ] in it and pushing in and
like who the [ __ ] knows what's gonna
happen
I couldn't agree with you more
same reason I mean I hate motivational
speakers and personal brands which is
why I do it
it's how I can it's the biggest the
biggest way it's I hate agencies I you
can't imagine what I feel about like the
partners of big companies like the
people that think they're the
establishment and I'm the snake oil
salesman because I mean they're ripping
people off so I get it actions just like
the last question actions always win and
then stepping from nutrition powers and
pills yep into doing more beverage any
advice on how to create almost separate
brand identity keep it all together I
think both can work I think it's how
healthy is the first brand identity
right and so if you're looking to do it
sooner and that one's not established
the way you want then I'd go separate a
lot of brands have cut started other
things that haven't worked they cut bait
and doesn't effect the mothership
you let him take you got it yeah all
right I'll go first so like it's really
interesting like I'm getting a massive
amount of perspective like as I go on
cuz I'm a bootstrap on entrepreneurs
yeah slowly growing and it's been a fun
process but it's like funny that the
further I get him the more I realize
like I don't know I don't have
experience doing this stuff and like
that's been cool because it's been a
slow steady long road like figure it out
as we go make tons of mistakes yep a lot
better so that's been all that's been
really good I'm like pumped with our
success and as you probably know like
when I got in the keto game like no one
was in the keto game I was the only I
wasn't the only bar I was only product
why should get into it so early because
I lost 70 pounds Wow um so and how did
you stumble on it the internet yeah yeah
yeah reddit yeah so like I started it by
tape like literally on the keto
syrrannite like that's that's where I
started understood ah those are my
people so the crazy thing is like this
journey has been all fun and games and
like oh yeah way beyond what I ever
expected then 2018 comes and now like
everyone knows what keto is yeah it's
blowing up and it's weird because it's
taken us years to figure out how to make
like a really shelf stable pocket right
it's like when you show up with ten
million dollars to a contract
manufacturer like you get that
shelf-stable bar on day one make sense
that's not where we came from that's
right so the weird thing for me is like
now is like this incredible blowing of
opportunity and we are getting a lot of
the benefits of that but there's a
million other people coming to the game
now our products better we have where we
have og status we have like the name we
have like a lot of things that are going
going for us but like worse I got anyone
the heat we're feeling quarter and I
guess what my question is or my viewing
it my like we'll just figure it out as
we go and get better too long the way
status is like it's getting suffocated
it's getting suffocated our FOMO is like
whoa like all these influencers and we
had we have like relationships with that
were oh geez
now there's 10,000 new ones because they
all just run the die in this past year
so as someone that's realizing that I
don't know everything and that like I
also want to take advantage of the
opportunity that's available it all
depends on how you're thinking about it
so my personal point of view then one
man's point of view is you stay in
perpetuity then you go through the
beating you're about to take yeah and
you come out the other side because
that's like the cliche thing that 98% of
the people like you do which is hire the
president that used to work at Kellogg's
to like run the business but she or he
is used more to me than being a small
brand they lose every time and I mean
every time and everyone's speaker yeah
of course everyone's spooking you power
and until they give like just go pick up
some dude so like a good example is like
we literally have been talking to a guy
that used to work and like all right so
now we worked out a retainer like he's
gonna help us out and like even that I'm
like man I don't like I got to take this
guy's word for some stuff cuz like he's
been in the industry life and you're and
you're good anyway and you're gonna lose
nine out of ten of those times yeah so
what do you just don't you just well I
mean look getting them like dictate how
much help as you can get but don't make
yourself vulnerable like yes I mean
there's been one long two hours of keep
the leverage leverages everything yes I
love you being on a retainer versus like
people give up pieces of their company
so so and by the way maybe you will
after he crushes it for six months and
you love him yeah but look even that
that was a smarter decision than nine
out of ten people make look I always
believed that people that go with their
natural instincts are better you know
give me people told you to give 10% 15%
of your company up to somebody who's
like it's the advice you get from people
all the time people that have never been
through it this is why I have no time
for MBAs and professors I just don't
want to take advice from anybody who's
never done it everything's cute in the
book
so what's your price then for me like Oh
like I need I want to ramp up my speed a
little bit I don't want to give up
leverage which so I still own 100% of
the company myself but I don't want to
miss out on the whole thing too I don't
wanna get smoked like you just do the
best again God didn't say you can take
duck you can take debt you want to take
that cool you can give a piece of your
equity and then you need to let that
need to go slow okay if you want cash
you're not saying anything other than I
might need some cash to accelerate my
business yeah I get it
so like we're doing some things that I'm
like okay well I can write a big check
here's my here's my thing here's my
thing it's highly likely that this will
be a tough chapter but how long do you
want to do this well that's a very fair
answer and that is the question yeah
it's fun it's fun until it's not after
18 months of getting your face beat in
well then what you exciting I mean look
all these things are about options
everything has trade-offs you know I
think that look I think that
direct-to-consumer capabilities of CBG
products are gonna grow exponentially
over the next 20 years so even though
you're gonna have a lot more competition
a lot more people gonna buy bars on the
internet and not at 7-eleven and
Kroger's so it just depends on the
supply and demand of the competitive set
is your your your competition's gonna
grow but if this demand of bars on the
internet or Ocado grows enough you won't
feel the pain it all just depends on
that there's too many variables outside
of this conversation that will play out
yeah you know I think this is why I keep
pushing like what are you up to like
he's up to selling businesses he's done
it twice now like that's what he was
about like I never want to sell Vayner
ever I want to use it for everything
else I do
you know you know they're in the process
of like having a second meaningful
business and that's what they want to
focus on because it's exciting it's
different than what like it really
really really matters where you are
you're so young so for me when you're so
young i I think it's great too I think
every kid should get their ass kicked
once cuz then it doesn't make you scared
of getting your ass kicked
so I like telling young entrepreneurs to
just keep going even if the company goes
out of business and they come here and
say you're a [ __ ] I'm like yeah I'm a
[ __ ] but you're 29 now and you've been
on both sides of it which means you a
pattern recognition which means when you
start your next thing next year at
thirty-one after a year of maybe getting
a job and just getting back on your feet
and if you're a savior that means you're
not gonna go into debt that's not like
you're gonna just lose upside well to me
that the only thing you're not gonna
lose is your brand you can lose all
three of the things you just mentioned
if people stop opening emails at any
kind of significant level if the ads on
Facebook get too expensive because
organics going only in one direction
that's just the flight of the game so I
want people in here to do LinkedIn right
now cuz LinkedIn organic is very good
and it won't be right you're always
going to where organics best.i when
everyone was crying about their Facebook
page organic three years ago I was
pumped cuz it reset you know made it
harder again yeah okay what's that let
me finish I saw Bob
smart we're good at a lot of things but
I wouldn't say most our experts at
anything so we do want to hire more
people for me to do I'm trying to think
like what expert that's what SEO like
video Amazon Holly what's the first one
we should focus oh sure you do you know
everything like I'm just a grinder -
you're a prat first yeah I mean the
first 30 people we hired here like what
you need what do you what do you want
like it's like you need what you want
like what do you want first
you want to be better at Amazon well you
need somebody that's great at Amazon
good you need somebody hardcore math
good fine we got a tongue we got a lot
of him reading fits me is a nice place
to live to like you know like I think
that um I think you need math but here's
the thing everybody thinks he's like
running a business is not like getting
had an even marriage you can get at the
board and you thought he was gonna be
the best he went the [ __ ] MIT and
he's gonna be the greatest you found out
he's a sexual predator you gotta fire
him like I don't understand how
everybody thinks they're gonna make
these decisions that in perpetuity are
gonna be perfect
I basically go the other way I think
every decision I make is a [ __ ]
mistake and then if something works out
it's a happy upside I'm being dead
[ __ ] serious by the way that's why I
don't judge or try to be over perfect I
make decisions I value the speed of the
decision over the right decision because
I can [ __ ] fix the wrong decision
that's why I've been able to build big
businesses fast
what somebody's gonna what do you think
of resin you think somebody whose gives
you a resume and interviews is give me
that's the most P art version of
themselves in the history of life do you
know what everybody's biggest flaw is
they've worked too hard sometimes I'm so
passionate about being great
I can work too hard and burn myself out
[ __ ] out of here right I've never
listened to anybody when you ask them
what's their flaw it's the biggest
[ __ ] humblebrag of all time
I'm such an expert that like sometimes I
make my team struggle to keep up with my
awesomeness [ __ ] you I think
everything's a mistake I'm thrilled when
it's worked out and once it actually is
a mistake I make a change that's why it
works all right so we run podcast lives
and we ask to edit tours he's one of
them there and what would be some of the
responsibilities that we should give our
minimum standard for a company our size
to be able to make sure that we're
constantly just feeding the different
mediums obviously we have our own
personal branding and the two companies
what do you think would be a good
strategy for them or go to the next
higher I well I think you need to
produce as much content as possible
I think volume is the breakthrough
concept to the point where like between
what I'm talking about between what I'm
doing with clients between like like I
literally I've been like kind of like
[ __ ] my like what's gonna be my next
book and like literally I make write a
book called volume like that's how much
I believe in it so the answer to your
question is as much as you can humanly
afford nothing you're about to say is no
if you can afford it yeah
we have flying back in the state back in
Arizona and we find that like yes we I
agree with your volume is a huge thing
but I feel like we create we create more
content video wise and everything then
we have time to edit and then on top of
that I also have like other
responsibilities aside from just the
video ended in your creating graphics I
also like Digimon cast yeah I do the
puck that's recording I manage our
websites I manage our social make sense
comes down to a very simple thing also
do you like for AC associates I take was
it the card orders sign ordinary thing
no no it's not it's not it's not at all
I hear this every day no no no no I
think it's actually very simple I'm like
that's cool and like as you should if
they want to produce that level of
content you're a human they've got an
allocation of dollars right and if they
want to that make sense seems like a
nice solid workload and clearly if there
was an if Karen was also here and she
did half of that stuff but a third of it
or two-thirds of it you would have more
output there's a reason my team went
from three people to 20 people
I wanted dramatically more output I also
wanted to train people to put into the
Vayner X machine so a lot of times
people
I don't need 22 I need probably 7 I'm
doing 22 so I can keep training people
so they can work so day two can be
successful got it so like I think I
think if you're really ambitious seven
people can really do some serious
[ __ ] damage if you do the media
person if you do you know video
collecting the video post-production
copy right copy batters you know
influence their organic distribution biz
dev and deals you know you could you
could DM you could message 700 Facebook
pages a day and ask them to distribute
your content people need content they're
getting pre-roll ads you're getting
exposure they think they're tricking you
because you're giving them content for
their [ __ ] inspire inspire inspire
komm page your pump because you're
getting the brand they're getting
pennies from the impressions you're
getting long-term dollars you could
that's a 15 hour day job business
development of distribution it could
also be seven people's 15 days jobs
you'll have four thousand websites
instead of 40 when there's a moment you
strike there is a moment in
communication right now that I think is
worth striking that's what this has all
been about with me because if there's a
downside of social media consumption
before voice escalates there may be just
a middle window just like 24 2014 was a
middle window to me 2013 12 trying to
remember what it was
Google was saturated proper was
appropriate you know search whatever
social was organic but not all the way
there yet Facebook didn't have its ad
product there wasn't any like crazy good
deal it's kind of like the economy is
now not buying businesses because
they're all overpriced it's too frothy
too much money in the system supply and
demand good time to sell your brands I
mean a lot of people in your positions
will be upset that they didn't sell
their you know somebody right now
turning down a twenty nine million
dollar deal from Kellogg's because she's
like well my popcorn brands gonna be a
hundred million and then the world
collapses and it's not or
[ __ ] up and disproportionally move their
allocations to Amazon and
direct-to-consumer and it's all timing
right that's what you're asking it's all
timing all these questions are timing to
me it's what makes my game so good as
it's forever so when you're playing a
game we're like you could give up 30
points in the third quarter and that's
okay but if you're like holding your
breath for an exit
then it's anxiousness but it should be
predicated on we don't know you do know
not a lot of people that know how to
sell a dollar on the internet let alone
a million dollars you do know you know
something else the real thing cool on on
that family note so I've got a customer
who actually my biggest customer is
situation bus company that just destroys
him with my products so they approached
me about helping them develop their own
product line I kind of flipped down so
I'm here for you no problem but if you
guys want to invest in one of my lines
wealthy take the ownership or just have
an investment in it and we're kind of at
a standstill of they're trying to make
the decision on which way to go and they
have the left they have the leverage so
I think what you did was smart a lot of
big companies will make private label
versions of their product for Walmart
because they have the leverage depends
on how big the boxes more than 30% of
your business you better make a deal
playing chicken with somebody owns a big
piece of your business is I can tell I
can tell I love the way I was waiting
for you I was gonna kill you but I was
like oh no he was smart no no it's
really good I was waiting I was like oh
yeah
no no you nailed it you you're gonna be
out yep yep it's the right thing for
your business whoever's closest to the
customer always wins they're closer to
customer you are
[Music]